la commission parlementaire du
développement régional au sein du
parlement européen s'occupe de tous les
points concernant la politique de
cohésion européenne et cette politique
elle est très importante c'est celle qui
vise à gérer l'équité de développement
de toutes les régions européennes et
bien le modem
le centre en général en france c'est la
famille de la décentralisation des
responsabilités locales des libertés
d'administration des collectivités
territoriales et ce concept de
décentralisation il s'applique
évidemment également à l'union
européenne
celle ci doit être proche de territoire
dans un dialogue plus directe avec les
élus les élus locaux sont les premiers
opérateurs des changements ou de
l'adaptation aux besoins de changement
ils sont les pros en première ligne pour
lutter contre le chômage pour lutter
contre les difficultés et pour équiper
leurs différents territoires les
transports la transition écologique la
préservation de la biodiversité les
politiques de culture et c'est pour cela
que les collectivités les mairies
notamment mais aussi les régions et les
départements sont des partenaires
privilégiés de l'union européenne
concrètement sur quoi les fonds
européens permet-il d'agir quelles sont
les actions concrètes de l'europe dans
les régions pour répondre à cette
question mais je veux revenir sur ce
moment particulier de crise est de pain
de nick nous vivons le premier fonds
d'aidé d'urgence qui a été développée
l'a été par les fonds européens
c'est 37 milliards d'euros qui ont été
débloqués en urgence et réfléchie vers
les régions pour qu'elles puissent agir
et intervenir au plus près en commandant
des masques en aidant des entreprises
par exemple à se convertir vers des
productions liées à la santé publique
et puis il y a ce nouveau budget de
l'union européenne qui va emprunter sur
les marchés pour redistribuer aux états
et permettent la relance et ça c'est de
la solidarité européenne
l'objectif est à la fois de soutenir
notre économie dans ces temps de crise
des d'agir en termes d'action sociale de
faire avancer la question de la
transition écologique et de continuer le
développement numérique
et puis enfin la commission la france et
l'allemagne et nous élus locaux
également nous sommes favorables à une
union européenne de la santé
évidemment l'union européenne ne doit
pas prendre les compétences et le dessus
sur les systèmes sociaux très
spécifiques de chaque état membre
mais l'union européenne a un vrai rôle
de coordination notamment sur l'achat
massif de vaccins auprès des grands
laboratoires pharmaceutiques pour
négocier d'égal à égal avec les
laboratoires
et puis ensuite les états-nations eux
organisent leur système de santé
et c'est enfin au niveau local que en
tant que maire nous mettons en oeuvre et
nous agissons concrètement sur le
terrain pour faire face à l'épidémie